i believe that we were all brought into
this universe for purpose
you exist for a very definite reason
if opportunity won't knock in your door
break them all
welcome to the global student
entrepreneur awards
51 different nationalities represented
their countries as the top
student entrepreneurs this is about who
is going to sit here and wow this planet
in the next 5 10
20 years rumento is an online
marketplace for students
i design an app where deaf people
communicate more easily
it's about creating happiness that's
what we do
he has an algorithm that can read the
baby's crying
and he's very hot so full package
i had a technology where i could make
synthetic chemicals but with the sun
this is a world-changing idea this is a
competition where people can come from
difficult backgrounds
and still make it my mom told me you
have a story that deserves to be heard
i'm so sorry everybody that comes here
wants to win the companies that exist
right now were made by someone
so why can't that someone be us
growing up i got bullied a lot i did my
best given what i had
if they can do it i can do it
i learn don't give up keep moving i
finally did it
i did something good in my life
[Music]
these uses girls that we don't really
know what we're up against
so we're going to prove them wrong
and the award goes to
you